at this altitude I can flat out for my
hands this episode is brought to you by
99designs I've used 99designs for ages
since even before podcasting was the
thing and I've used them for all sorts
of graphic design needs they are fast
and they are convenient whether you need
a logo a website book cover or anything
else I've done competitions for instance
for book covers related to the 4-hour
body 99designs makes great design
accessible to everyone and it makes the
process so much easier and I use them
recently for artwork and illustrations
inside of mic'd how of Seneca set of
books so this is a collection of stoic
writing and modern interviews and so on
so for the Tao of Seneca I decided to
use their one-to-one project surface in
this case you invite a specific designer
to your project agree on a price and
then work together until you're
satisfied and the artwork just blew my
mind you have to check it out I kid you
not so you can check out some of the
artwork from Toph Seneca as well as some
artwork and logos and so on that your
fellow listeners have had made at
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim
that's 99designs com forward slash Tim I
really suggest you check it out and
right now you guys can receive a free
$99 upgrade on your first project this
gets you I think a hundred and thirty
percent more submissions so people who
want to work with you and give you first
drafts of what you're looking for to
access your free design please visit
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim and
click the link on the landing page
that's 99designs comm forward slash Tim
[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to another episode of the Tim Ferriss
show this is Tim Ferriss speaking and I
should clarify that this episode is an
edition of the Tim Ferriss radio hour
where I share the patterns and themes of
world-class performers that I've
identified after more than 300 guests on
the podcast this particular episode is
going to explore success what does that
mean what a slippery dangerous term and
the particular guests I selected for
this episode i would say represent not
only achievement but also appreciation
and a well-rounded version of what I
consider to be a successful human being
and by any objective measure certainly
financially or otherwise I have
interviewed some of the more successful
people on the planet and in the next
hour we will revisit specific
conversations that discuss the tips
disciplines habits and mindsets perhaps
most importantly that separate
world-class performers who reach their
goals from those who fall short this
episode includes wisdom from Derek
Siver's I learned this the hard way at
my last company because we had a quarter
million customers so when I'd send out
an email to everyone if any sentence was
it all unclear in any way I'd get like
50,000 confused replies from people we
also talked to Tony Robbins you got to
become an investor you got to be an
owner not a consumer right and the way
to do that frankly we all know but very
few people do and that's you take a
percentage you lock it down it you never
see it it's automated and you put it
aside for investment and that just
occurs you'll hear from my good friend
Chris Sacca venture capital I mean it's
totally unfair people give me their
money I draw a management fee off it so
they pay me to take their money and
invest it for them legendary investor
Reed ollio I think three things make up
a successful life by and large first you
have to have aa daesh's goals big dream
and we can't talk success without
including Sir Richard Branson one of the
best things my parents taught me and
going back a long way if I ever said
anything about anybody they would sit me
in front of the mirror for 10 minutes
and in order to sort of let me know how
badly it reflect
as a preface before we jump into the
conversations with these guests I
thought it might be helpful to set the
stage and that is with an observation
that I have made certainly in
interacting personally with many of my
podcast guests and many name brand folks
in Silicon Valley and elsewhere and that
is the following the superheroes you
might have in your mind the idols icons
elite athletes billionaires and so on
are nearly always walking flaws who have
maximized one or two strengths now I'm
not saying that as true of the people in
this episode but in general this is true
and there are some mutants there are
some freaks of nature who are the
equivalent of the Usain Bolt's of the
business world for instance but they are
rare in general humans are very very
imperfect creatures which would be a
generous way to put it and you don't
succeed and most of the people I've
interviewed don't succeed in quotation
marks because they or you have no
weaknesses instead you succeed because
you find your unique strengths and focus
on developing habits around those
strengths and you can get only a few
things right consistently and outperform
almost everybody else and I think that
for instance the investment styles of
Warren Buffett and Charlie Munger who
are both brilliant granted but who focus
on being consistently not stupid not
consistently smarter than everybody else
which perhaps is a form of being smarter
and so on and so forth but it's
important to keep in mind rather than
putting these people on a pedestal and
viewing what they do is unreachable and
in a way then absolving yourself of the
responsibility of trying to improve
yourself that everyone is fighting a
battle in his fought battles you know
nothing about
there are many mega successful people
who battle with depression with pasts
that might include alcoholism you name
it and that is not necessarily true of
the people in this episode but I think
it's important to underscore that so
that you think that through incremental
improvement you can actually put
yourself in a position to achieve
seemingly impossible things and that is
the truth
so everyone is fighting about all you
know nothing about you
icons in this episode are no different
everyone struggles so take solace in
that and now without further ado let's
jump into some of the things that
separate those who achieve what they set
out to do from those who don't let's
start with Derek Siver's at zippers on
Twitter SIV ers he is one of my favorite
human beings think of him as a
philosopher King programmer master
teacher and perhaps merry prankster
originally a professional musician and
circus clown whole long story
behind that - listen to my long
interview with him at tim dot blog
forward slash derek derek created CDBaby
in 1998 it became the largest seller of
independent music online with 100
million dollars in sales for more than a
hundred fifty thousand musicians in 2008
derek sold CDBaby for 22 million dollars
giving the proceeds to a charitable
trust for music education he is a
frequent speaker at the TED conference
with more than 5 million views of his
talks since 2011 he has published 34
books
what including a book titled anything
you want which I've personally read at
least a dozen times when you think of
the word successful who is the first
person who comes to mind and why well
the first answer to any question isn't
much fun because it's just automatic
right like what's the first painting
that comes to mind
Monalisa name a genius Einstein who's a
composer Mozart but this is the subject
of the book Thinking Fast and Slow by
Daniel Kahneman there's the instant
unconscious automatic thinking and then
there's the slower conscious rational
deliberate thinking so I'm really really
into the slower thinking like breaking
my automatic responses to the things in
my life and slowly thinking through a
more deliberate response instead and
then for the things in life for an
automatic response is useful I can
create a new one consciously so like
what if you asked when you think of the
word successful who's the third person
that comes to mind and why are they
actually more
[ __ ] than the first person that came
to mind well in that case the first
person would be Richard Branson because
he's like the stereotype right he's like
the Mona Lisa for success to me and
honestly you might be my second answer
but we could talk about that a different
time and my third and real answer after
thinking it through is that we can't
know without knowing a person's aims
right like what if Richard Branson set
out to live a quiet life but like a
compulsive gambler he just can't stop
creating companies well then that
changes everything and we can't really
call him successful anymore what are the
most common misconceptions about you
know I feel pretty understood I don't
think people are thinking about me
enough to conjure up any misconceptions
you know we think the goal of writing
and communication is to be understood
but I think a better goal is just making
sure that you're not misunderstood I
learned this the hard way at my last
company because we had a quarter million
customers so when I'd send out an email
to everyone if any sentence was it all
unclear in any way I'd get like 50,000
confused replies from people which would
take my team like a thousand man-hours
to go through so now anything I put out
into the public is rewritten and edited
like crazy until I think it's as clear
as can be
what do you world-class at that people
might not realize or what are your
friends know your world class at that
the rest of world doesn't know about
I've got the world's longest attention
span I'll just sit down and do one task
for like 12 hours straight or all day
for 25 days in a row you know I actually
I love that my kid is getting it from me
by the way that we play like whenever we
play I never say let's go time to go we
just do something until he's ready to
move on like he'll lead me to the river
and just throw rocks in the water for a
couple hours and then we'll go to the
ocean and build a fort out of driftwood
for hours and then draw in the sand with
shells until he's
sleepy and we've always done it this way
since he was you know like a
one-year-old other families would come
play on the playground for 20 or 30
minutes at a time but we would just be
there for hours with him fully immersed
in some newly invented game and what's
funny is that nobody else can hang with
us like this like not even his mom
everyone else gets so bored people ask
if I meditate or do yoga but nope
my daily life feels like working
meditation even being with my kid is
like meditation as you can tell ok now
we're doing the format today where we're
going to open up the phone to collars
but you know since it's Christmas day
phones are a little slow hey there's a
call hi Derrick this is Dave DiGiovanni
from Kalamazoo Michigan in the USA
thanks for doing the podcast with Tim
thanks for taking this question you've
helped a lot of people make money and
I'm just wondering if success in
business has to be more complicated than
that I get overwhelmed reading all the
you know there's so much content out
there on how to make money how to grow
your business how to start a business
and I'm just wondering if business needs
to be more complicated than coming up
with ideas on how to help other people
succeed thank you
well let's talk about two things simple
versus complicated and easy versus hard
so look at running if you talk with
people who hate running you'll hear them
say uh first you have to get your
running clothes then you get dressed and
then you got to put on your shoes and
you got to lace them up just right well
then you guys stretch and then you gotta
warm up then afterwards you need to cool
down and you need to shower it's such a
pain but if you talk with people that
love running they'll say yeah you just
pop out for a quick run and if you ask
them about the steps involved they'll
say there's just one you know you just
run so knowing that we have this human
nature to think of things we like as
simple and things we don't as
complicated well you can use this to
deliberately simplify how you think of
something you're avoiding making it more
appealing so an ultramarathon is simple
you just run a hundred miles to the end
but that doesn't mean it's easy right so
success in business can be simple you
just find a need that people are proving
they're willing to pay for and then find
a profitable way to solve that need for
them but it doesn't mean it's easy so
what you have to do is notice in your
mind when your complications are holding
you back and then turn the dial towards
simplicity in your mind so you just jump
out the door and start running but then
notice in your results when we're
simplified approach might be holding you
back all right like perhaps you are
using only one tool in your toolbox and
you need to learn others and as for all
the business advice out there well you
know if information was the answer then
we'd all be billionaires with perfect
ABS so really you and ya you listening
to this most of you probably just need
to shut that [ __ ] off put your blinders
on and get out the door and start
running metaphorically speaking that is
hi this is Tobin in Boulder Colorado and
my question is what should someone ask
to determine their own utopia Thanks
first ask yourself is this in theory or
in practice like have you proven from
your experience that this is really what
works best for you whatever idea you
have you have to challenge it you need
to argue against it because there are so
many things that seem great
in theory right like for example say
you're living in a little apartment in a
noisy city and so you think that you'd
be happy if only you had a big place out
in the silent country and so you do it
you splurge you buy a place or you sign
a year-long lease and then you move out
to the country and oh after two months
you realize that you miss too many
things about the big city you made the
wrong prediction and it happens the
other way too right like people moving
from the quiet burbs to the big city or
somebody who's an employee that things
they just be happy if they could quit
their job and start their own business
and oops doesn't always work out like
that so my recommendation is to do
little tests like try a few months of
living the life you think you want but
leave yourself an exit plan being open
to the chance the big chance that you
might not like it after actually trying
it the best book about this subject is
stumbling on happiness by Daniel Gilbert
his recommendation is to talk to a few
people that are currently where you
think you want to be and ask them for
the pros and cons and then trust their
opinions since they're right in it not
just remembering or imagining this is
James McGill from psycho Ireland my
question is how do you define success
and what habits or skills are most
important to living a successful life
thanks okay well first let's define
success ask yourself if you think Robin
Williams and Philip Seymour Hoffman were
successful actors I think it's a tough
call like my first reaction is yes but
the more I think about it my answer
moves halfway towards no as a different
example think of someone you know who
that you'd consider be like the
definition of a total loser and now you
give that person a million dollars are
they now a winner of course not and that
sounds like a contrived example but a
lot of fame and fortune is dropped into
the lap of people who were just the
right face in the right place at the
right time but are actually miserable
awful people by any definition so the
more you think it through the more you
realize that you have to define success
first by your inner game not some
outside measure of money or fame right
mastering yourself your mind and your
actions but now if you only master
yourself and you don't help anyone else
well then we'd call you happy but like
nobody would define you as successful so
the very definition of success must
include how much
you helped others and I'll bet that if
you helped thousands of people even if
you didn't ultimately profit from it but
you were personally miserable well we
might still call you successful because
you helped others right so the point is
if you want to be undeniably successful
you need to both master yourself and
help others don't focus on the money or
the fame the real success is mastering
your emotions and actions and actually
helping lots of people so the definition
but now you asked what habits your
skills are most important to living a
successful life well by this definition
habits and skills number one the skill
and habit of managing your state and
your emotional reactions and actions
number two
knowing what people need in general and
what you need in particular number three
people skills how to see things from the
other person's point of view and how to
communicate from their point of view and
number four the ability to focus learn
practice and apply what you learn if you
can do those four things you can do
anything you can first be happy without
depending on anyone or anything in
particular and then you can understand
what people need learn how to provide it
and make sure they know it next up is
Tony Robbins at Tony Robbins on Twitter
and elsewhere the world's most famous
performance coach he's advised everyone
from Bill Clinton to Mikhail Gorbachev
to Serena Williams and Leonardo DiCaprio
to Oprah who calls him superhuman by the
way that's Oprah calling someone that I
love Tony's work and his personal power
to set which I listened to in my POS
used minivan while I was commuting
during my first job helped me start my
first company and recently I should say
over the last several years I've had the
chance to work with Tony get to know him
directly and it's been an incredible
experience Tony has worked with many
legendary investors including Paul Tudor
Jones who he's coached for
more than 10 years Ray Dalio Carl Icahn
David Swensen Kyle bass and many more
these are the heart to interview
unicorns who consistently beat the
market despite the fact that it's
considered by impossible by many folks
and Tony has done a great job of I would
say condensing the lessons he's learned
from them and some guys are like
Templeton I got multiple times for he
died it's like wait for the bloodletting
no one on the streets that's on the
streets but it's like when maximum
pessimism hits that's when you make all
your money that's what he did and then
there's the guys like Bogle which is
it's the index baby and and Wednesdays
even Warren Buffett it's the index baby
so they hold the approaches but what's
in common I think is I tell you four
things our son stood out and one is
overly simplistic and that's why people
don't pay attention to but these guys
pay attention to it they don't lose half
the peak of winking is not losing and
they are obsessed every single one was
obsessed they're not losing money I mean
a level of obsession that's
mind-boggling and it isn't just these
investors you know Sir Richard Branson
for example you know people see Richard
and he's such an outgoing playful crazy
guy's kind of introverted that some
areas but when it comes to athletics and
taking on challenges he's out in the
world but you know his first question
every business has left the downside now
I protect it right like what he did his
piece with virgin and that's a big risk
gonna start an airline
he went to Boeing and negotiated a deal
they could send the planes back up it
didn't work out he wasn't liable but
that's the love these guys think so they
look to see how do I not lose money
first because the average person has no
clue if I lose 50% in 2008 well guess
what you got to make a hundred percent
to get even not 50% because your
principles gone down so it's like people
don't understand you lose 60 percent
it's 200 percent to get even and so the
average person you know lives in a world
where they try not to lose money but
they're not obsessed these are upset
second thing they all have in common
every single one of them is obsessed
with asymmetrical risk for war which is
a big word it simply means they're
looking to use the least amount of risk
to get the max amount of upside and
that's what they live for
so I'll give an example Paul tooters
when I first went to do the turnaround
Paul was having some challenging times
he'd broken his leg you know think about
this
he did better than anybody in history
the world during the biggest stock
market drop in history literally and
then he went to the mountain he went to
the moon now what and so lost a bit of
the edge and you know got involved in
other things and so forth and now he's
got a broken leg he's not going the
office I gotta come inside to go watch
that film that's first thing I did I
went white tennis shoes I wanted to go
see I have nothing about him study his
physiology the way he used to move this
guy's not moving at all what his face
was like I would breathe tone of his
voice
what would the physical strategies what
were the psychological strategy or the
financial strategies I got to go you
know to Druckenmiller and Soros I look
at that system back there was
unbelievable see what was he like then
to put the plan together to do this turn
around and when I started making those
shifts in Hammer you can see the shift
happen immediately he got really
exciting I got hooked on what was gonna
happen so as I did this same process
basically I guess what I was triggered
on think about do things once I did the
same process during his interviews I
didn't just look at the training
strategies I looked at the psychology
what set it up but here's what I found
with Paul Tudor very beginning in him
back on track when he was at his best he
made sure every single trade had what he
called a 5 to 1 that means if he was
gonna risk a dollar he wasn't about to
risk unless he was certain he was gonna
make 5 now you're not always right so
guess what if I risk it all to make 5
and I'm wrong I never asked another
dollars don't make 4 I can be ruined 4
times out of 5 it's still breakeven
their secret is not the theta they're
not wrong if they stepped himself up
where they risk small amounts for big
rewards proportionally oh you know he's
right I won out three times he still
makes 20 percent so the average person
wrists a dollar trying to make how much
dollar ten if I could get 10% Wow my
dollar I have 20% would be unbelievable
how often can you be wrong you're in the
hole you're starting for the hole you
gotta go back up so they're a
significant worth like I was with Kyle
bass and how fast risk - check this out
in the middle of the subprime crisis he
made two billion dollars out of 30
million because he risked for every six
cents he risked he had an upside of a
dollar yeah six cents 400 well you could
be wrong 15 times and you still okay in
that area I mean he was brilliant
figure it out he's a genius figured out
but that risk reward is why this he
showed his kids he ties so how do I
teach us to the average investor and he
said well you could teach the way I
taught my kids I said you nearly goes
we bought nickels I said what do you
mean he bought nickels he said well I
did research I had this question that's
another thing that all these guys do
they ask a better question we talked
about they get better answers right
better quality question better quality
answer what's wrong with me you'll come
up with stuff how did I make this happen
no matter what they'll come up with
different answers so his question was
where in the world is the riskless trade
with total upside and he started looking
around he said I'm worried about
inflation so he decided well gosh of all
the currencies in the world a nickel
what it's made of today it's not made
mostly of nickel by the way he said it's
costing the US government nine and half
cents to make a nickel that's hard
government functions it's been almost
ten cents to make something with half as
much the Pentagon plans so he said but
you know what just the actual material
value right is 628 or whatever was six
something six and a half will call for
round numbers so he said if I buy a
nickel it's never going less than nickel
I she believed the US government's gone
so I've got something that never goes
down in value so I got a guaranteed
return you know I'm not gonna lose my
principle but day one it's worth 36%
more than the day I bought it
how many investments can you have a 100%
guarantee of no Osun of 36 percent I
said yeah but that's melt value and I
saw they passed the law a few years ago
Charlie Rangel over it was want to push
it through he goes yeah but Tony said
that doesn't matter let me tell you why
you said look at pennies when they
changed it from pure copper to 10 and
all the things they changed what
happened to the old pennies there's a
scarcity of them and now a penny from
those days they're worth 2 cents it's a
hundred percent more valuable so he said
that at some point the government cannot
continue to do something cost twice as
much some point they'll make a change in
the materials and then all these nickels
were the ugly warm out so he said I just
showing my kids here's a risk you you
need to think different than everybody
else don't think I have to take huge
risks for huge rewards say how do I take
no risk and get your drawers and because
you asked that question continuously you
believe an answer you got it
so you know he said listen if I could
put mine to convert my entire wealth and
males right
you're insane because I haven't say but
it's the best possible fundamental
investment he started telling me how to
do keep on 40 million nickels Wow so he
can legitimately do like the Scrooge
McDuck backstroke you told me the
difference is the one you know there are
differences we've spent how is the
difference is by things you suppose
what's a wine because then it give
something Universal that apply
absolutely the other one for them is
they absolutely beyond a shot of a doubt
know they're gonna be wrong you will
look on these talking ads on television
of people screaming you and hitting
bells and telling you what to buy and
they're right right right the best on
earth or a values right the the babbles
the you know I don't give it he'll you
talk about you want to look at Carl
Icahn they all know they're gonna be
wrong so they set up a NASA location
system that will make them successful
they all agree asset allocation is the
single most important investment there
was one person in terms of your vehicle
that was the most important thing about
how they attacked it passive allocation
was the element there and the last one
is they are their lifelong learners I
mean these people are machines like you
like me like Peter like most of people
you and I share his friends they just
are obsessed with knowing more now
because the more they know the more they
realize what they didn't know and then
they apply that and they go to another
level and every time you think you're
the best you can be in anything in life
your body or motion spirit your finances
there's always another level and these
guys live by and the last one that I
found almost all the more real givers
not just give us on the surface like
money giving that's wonderful but really
passionate about giving and it showed up
once they saw what I was doing was
legitimate that was really real that I
mean then they're opening up three hours
of their time something these guys will
never get I think it was Dalia who said
something along the lines of like losers
react winners anticipate actually maybe
but that's because yeah but the point
being that the and I guess Mark Twain
quotes also in there which was what
history doesn't repeat itself but it
rhymes
so there are going to be crashes there
are going to be Black Swan events and
you want to have a plan in place for
when that happens exactly and Ray Dalio
actually said something in there that
stuck with me brutally he said I don't
care what it is that you think you're
great at investing in or you like most
people invest in what they like real
estate or stocks or bonds or what they
think they're good at or what they were
raised with he said whatever asset class
you invest in I promise you in your
lifetime it will drop no less than 50
and more likely 70% at some point and he
said that is why you absolutely must
diversify because you're saying but I
could make so much more in this side you
know I've had people throughout the
years I teach this market theory this
idea that if you want to do is make a
sonication simple it sounds like such a
big word yeah it's just buckets some way
money's gonna go on a secure bucket that
bucket is like a church people I'm gonna
it's not going away
it's very secure type investments its
upside is not gigantic in terms of speed
but you know what the compounding
process if you give it enough time those
low returns are giant returns still but
you're not gonna lose and then there's
this bucket called what most people call
growth bucket I call a risk growth
because it's really risk first yeah and
I'm out I'm taking bigger risks for
potentially greater rewards and now the
question is how do i balance these am i
6040 5050 80/20 and that's designed
really by three things number one what's
your real respond it's not what you
think it is yeah and they're going the
same you know I do it I do these wealth
mastery programs in a few years and
variably I'll do some crazy thing like
I'll say everything up make change they
look at make or make change and they
start reaching their pockets and they
can change let's somebody to pull out
five bucks and ten bucks see some people
in a hundred dollars and no someone come
up and they'll take it and give them
five bucks and they're like you know how
to react so this goes on for three or
four minutes the music's going on okay
stop right said how are they going like
I'm talking about something else and
then invariably
somebody's like hey wait a second I want
my $100 back so what are you talking
about they said I minded or like the
game's over I said what do you what do
you think the game was over do you think
the game had ever gone over all right
and who said it was your hundred dollars
yeah all right and it's like the it
takes a while with fire they finally get
you know I'm stressed about $100
what do think is gonna happen when you
lose a million or half a million or a
hundred thousand or ten grand I mean
your risk tolerance is not we thinking
of so if I don't your astonishes and we
got great ways to do down the book and
then you figure out really how much time
do you have if you're younger you got
more time to make mistakes and so you
can make bigger risks you know you got
time on your part news four and then the
next piece is how much is your cash flow
what's that that's gonna be the real
file if you look at those three things
now you can decide how much goes in my
secure bucket how much goes my growth
and if you don't make that decision it's
the most important investment decision
of your life recording everybody I
interviewed like what percentage secure
what percentage growth no risk then when
things come up you're always gonna go
for the growth risk so this looks so
sexy and exciting and I can't tell you
how many people over the years have done
this they're telling me why when they
put money over here when I've got this
real estate I'm making 120% of a friend
though some of the first big condos in
Vegas back in the boom time and he he
actually what to my programs soul of
business he had made 200 million dollars
invested in these condos started
building the panorama towers and places
that nature and he was up to like three
quarters of building I kept saying them
dude take some of your growth money and
put it in a secure bucket right I'm how
many times I told you this goes tone I
love you I made two hundred million
dollars gives you but now and you know
I'm really I like what I touch goes the
gold of listen is he gone I'm gone I
love your brother but I said you many
times of the conversation and then guess
what happens in 2008 how much you think
he was worth three-quarters of a billion
dollars he groaned that rapidly in those
short ears we think happened to his
network I'm guessing it went down
according to the Ray Dalio prediction
how about minus 400 million he didn't
just lose what he had he lost everything
added beyond so then he's trying to go
she ate right themself out so most
people don't put enough in the security
bucket is the lesson and a guy like
value provide you a strategy that's got
great sustainability but there are many
approaches in the book but you do have
to decide how much is secure how much is
growth and I show you how to do that
Chris Sacca at Saka SACC a was once the
cover story of the midis issue of forbes
magazine and i've known him for some
time but that's what happens when you
are for instance an early stage investor
in companies like Twitter uber Instagram
Kickstarter and many more chris is the
the name the face behind what will most
certainly be the most successful venture
capital fund of all time
lower case one here are a few thoughts
on success that I found fascinating what
are the commonalities or are there
commonalities when you look across these
founders for whom success and massive
scale just seems predestined what are
the commonalities well I think something
so we'll we'll take Evan Travis examples
but but across our most successful
founders you know let's use a Matt Matt
Mullenweg
fertile rice that's a that's a
billion-dollar company now billion plus
these guys are all incredible incredible
listeners so when they do open their
mouth it can be bombastic and offensive
and aggressive and in-your-face but
they're all incredible listeners and I
don't just mean in casual conversation I
mean these guys go out of their way to
interview other people they really if
you catch EV he's got a notebook always
and if you ask him to see if you're you
know last few pages of the notebook
he's just meeting with other people
who's you know billionaires and and kind
of leaders whose jobs might not overlap
with his at all but from whom he's
learning voracious reader part of why
medium started was he was really back
deep in a long-form content when he took
a break from Twitter and so that guy is
just constantly learning studying
studying and so when he speaks it
matters but he's listening more than he
speaks you know that about mullenweg one
of the most thoughtful people I've never
seen anyone read as many books as that
guy does and retain all the knowledge
Olympic and he also it's a bean he
listens to anyone that he's sitting down
with mhm
doesn't matter if it's you know the
waitress or a primary school teacher
we've done a lot of traveling together
he was on the podcast also
very good listener yeah and so and again
you just look across the board these
guys are learning they're modeling
they're constantly researching they're
gathering data you know Travis would
think it a competitive disadvantage for
you to know exactly what's going on in
his head sometimes so he'll listen and
and it's an amazing talent I think Drew
is a commonality across those people
with the the investing game that you've
obviously been a participant in for
quite a while now you have to say no a
lot and I was you know took a close look
at at poker in the last year with the TV
show and there were a couple of quotes
that came up quite a bit along the lines
of you know I made my money sitting not
playing hands and but but that having
been said what are some of the deals the
the whales that got away yeah so first
of all I mean this is a rigged game
right man and I'm just looking to make
it even more rigged so for those who
don't know venture capital I mean it's
totally unfair people give me their
money I draw a management fee off it so
they pay me to take their money and
invest it for them if I make money then
I pay them back the management fee and
then after that we split the profits and
I get a really big chunk of the profits
and if I lose money
that's fine I don't know it doesn't come
out of my pocket I keep my fee and my
investors lose money
that's how this industry works that's
bananas right and at some point it's
gonna break because it it's you've also
incepted me with the term bananas which
I've started using compulsively inácio
also has done the same thing who works
with Chris yeah it's it's just an
unforgivably unfair rigged game that's
in favor of the venture capitalist and
so so that the reality is the risk of an
investor doesn't begin to compare to the
risk of a founder and so you know that's
one thing it kind of drives me crazy
sometimes about some investors and I
love the entrepreneurial spirit that
goes into building a firm I mean I built
my firm from scratch and there's
certainly founder type lessons in there
but
your cashflow positive from day one when
you start a venture fund and your your
downside is incredibly limited by the
structure the fun so so that said what
it allows me to do is place some bets on
some stuff that I I'd like to think
success is inevitable those things but I
can take I can look at the risk analysis
and say okay it's a binary outcome a one
or a zero and some of those things just
don't get there you know one of my one
of my kind of constant recurring
nightmares about the stuff I passed on
no that's exactly that's what I was
that's what I was trying to ask you know
I've done some deals where I thought it
was gonna be a lot bigger and you know
it ends up going away but so the Dropbox
guys I met those guys very early on
while they're still in Y Combinator I
got an early look you know I had an
opportunity to the deal and I pulled
those guys who said I was like hey look
at Google we were using a version of
this called platypus you know which
became g-drive and they're gonna crush
you guys man so you should probably find
some other product to pivot to the they
give you a pat on the head and welcome
yeah no I mean it's when I see drew the
CEO Dropbox I bring it up before he can
that's this I just get I get it out
there right away the Airbnb guys that
why common are same thing right business
an amazing business and wanted to be
proud of - I mean that's I'm really
jealous I'm not in that business not
just for the money but I love what they
do I'm really admire them a lot and
their culture but at the time they were
they were allowing you to rent out a
room in somebody's house while the owner
was still there and that just seemed
really scary to me and I pulled the guys
aside I was just like guys you know
somebody's gonna get raped or murdered
in one of these houses and the blood is
gonna be on your hands
I've literally saw that out loud to them
what's that worth like 15 or 20 billion
now now in fairness you you're probably
not wrong right I met at a certain scale
at scale it has to happen it's gonna
yeah yeah I mean I like to say sometimes
like when you think about scale like
someone who works at Walmart murdered
someone last night right there's just no
doubt about it
at that scale with a few million
employees one of them
somebody last night you have to look at
it like Edward Norton in Fight Club like
an actuarial analysis yeah for insurance
which is terrifying but that's the
reality of big numbers but there's one
other famous one there's a bunch of
these but actually I'll give you to Nick
cuz I wasn't reminded until recently
Nick Woodman from GoPro came to Google
now I wasn't an investor at the time but
I did a lot of Google's investments and
partnerships and so Eric Schmidt CEO
Google said hey will you come in here
and sit with this pitch you know he's a
friend of a friend said we got to meet
this guy so Woodman comes in with GoPro
and Eric's like I don't know and I was
like we'd be we'd be foolish to do this
deal how's this guy from Santa Cruz
gonna compete with all these Asians and
building hardware you know you can't you
can't hold a candle like the Taiwanese
and the Koreans was like no dice man let
this guy go and I think I introduced him
to somebody over YouTube just as a
consolation I saw that dude this winter
skiing he's worth like three or four
billion dollars now and he didn't forget
that meeting so and then the snapchat
guys I gave a talk in LA and they came
up to me I never met them before they
came up after the talk and said we're
big fans we'd really like to work with
you and I was like yeah sure
I mean I know you guys were up to
something cool I admire it I took like
eight weeks to set up the meeting and by
then the benchmark guys had done that
deal yeah that's okay oh my god I can't
imagine how much money we've left on the
table as a result of that so you know
I'm like the same when I'm wrong I'm
wrong when I'm right I'm really really
right Ray Dalio
at Ray Dalio on Twitter is one of the
100 most influential people in the world
according to time and one of the 100
wealthiest people in the world according
to Forbes because of his unique
investment principles that have changed
industry's CIO magazine dubbed him quote
the Steve Jobs of investing end quote
ray believes his success is the result
of principles he's learned codified and
applied to his life in business those
principles are detailed in his book a
play titled principles and he included
some of his wisdom in our interview
if we flash back to when you first began
Bridgewater associates so out of your
two-bedroom apartment at 26 years old do
you recall any of your first big wins or
things that you considered big wins at
the time and I'd love to just hear you
describe what made those big win in
other words the thinking behind it the
funny thing is I can hardly ever
remember my big wins I do remember my
big losses we could talk about those too
it's so it's so funny because you know I
look at it and I said well I I guess I
must have had a bunch of wins or
successes because of you know how things
have went you know what the business is
good and done well and all of that but
like I think of my history and I really
think of those mistakes and I think
that's so great because it shows that
that's a much better learning tool but
okay so my big wins you know no I think
about that at that time I think no I the
things I remember with the with the fun
things but the guy you know guys I
played rugby with and parties and and
those tons of things I don't remember a
particularly big winning well I do
remember some things you know I remember
one time when we got the Kodak account
mm-hmm again I was muscian it's okay
here's a guy and he's analyzing the
markets and then he has a small team of
people he's analyzing the markets and so
I didn't have a long track record and I
didn't have an institution and a you
know sort of competing with the big
institutions of the world the JP
Morgan's and everybody and and by the
way we beat them
well anyway which shows that the
individuals the powers within the end of
it
but anyway I remember when we got the
Kodak account because at the time Kodak
was you know a big important client and
them giving us that account was a big
deal for us because it was kind of a
stamp of institutional approval and it
was all I remember you know the money
mattered too because we would know that
we were a bit more financially secure so
I remember that as a big win and I
remember it so terrifically because we
were asked to submit research
information and we were just a small
team of people and you know we stayed up
all night and with you know pizza and
beer and all of that and I remember it
so sweetly because it was the dream of
making our miracle happen and we and
pulling together
that's the meaningful relationships part
I believe that I want meaningful work
and meaningful relationships and so that
was what that was about and we got the
account and we won and that was a you
know that was a big deal why did you
guys win I think it's a combination of
being you know totally unconventional
and having better processes and then
there's a hell of a lot of determination
I think three things make up a
successful life by and large first you
have to have audacious goals big dreams
then when you are headed toward those
goals you're gonna have problems you're
gonna deal with reality you have to deal
with those problems in that reality
realistically learning from mistakes
writing down those principles on the
like so that's the second part dealing
with reality in a practical way where
you learn about mistakes and then the
third is determination because if you're
going for your goals and you're
encountering your mistake
and you're learning and you do that with
determination you're gonna get better
all the time you can't help but get
better and you do that along in a amount
of time and you're going to far exceed
your dreams my success is far exceeded
what I ever imagined you know one bit at
a time and it's just that process if you
were to conversely look at intelligent
people who are unhappy what do you think
the primary causes of that unhappiness
are I think it goes back to this notion
of meaningful work of meaningful
relationships
intelligence and Happiness probably have
no correlation with each other in
studies the its repeatedly been shown
and money is very little correlated with
happiness the highest correlation with
happiness is community am i part of a
community do I feel connections with
other people that's been you know
literally genetically programmed into us
from it's estimated between a million
and two million years ago before it was
we were even mankind so that sense of
meaningful relationships I think is very
very important and if you have
meaningful work like you're on a mission
and you have meaningful relationships
and III think it's almost impossible not
to be happy I mean they'll be unhappy
moments in your life that you encounter
this thing or that but the people who
are unhappy seem to be missing those
things last but certainly not least we
have Sir Richard Branson at Richard
Branson on Twitter and everywhere else
founder and chairman of the Virgin Group
a world-famous entrepreneur adventurer
activist and business icon he has
launched a dozen billion-dollar
businesses and hundreds of other
companies I loved our conversation and
highly recommend you check it out of
course listen to the whole thing but
here are a few highlights you might find
you strike me as a really good
negotiator buy by necessity you'd have
to be if you had say a would-be
entrepreneur or a university senior
someone who's about to graduate and go
into the real world and you wanted they
tell you that they want to become a very
good negotiator a very good deal maker
how would you train them or what would
you recommend they do or read to become
a better negotiator or deal maker
because you seem very very astute and
subtle and structuring things in in very
smart ways what would you say to someone
who wants to develop that skill set
I'm sure must be ways of being taught it
but in my opinion nothing beats these
personal experience in my education was
you know being thrown into the jungle
being thrown into the real world age 15
or 16 and to survive and it was an
incredible education and you know I
learnt about everything in life you know
you know have all the met met people all
over the world I you know I had to do a
lot of different variations you know I
think as I've got older I've realized
the the one of the most important things
about a negotiation is striking a deal
that is fair to both sides I also
realized as I get older that you've
always come across the same people time
and time again in life and so your
reputation is everything you know in my
new book branding my opportunity I talk
about our dealings with Delta and how
you know the day they felt that they'd
leg dis over an in a clause in a
contract and how they they they came to
us to rectify it and you know this
that's something I'll never forget in
and most likely will be you know
partners from Delta for the rest of my
life because of that you know that you
know that kind of that kind of approach
and you know so I think you know if you
if you realize that your reputation is
all you have and your personal
reputation and the reputation of your
brand then you've got to make sure that
you're you're you're negotiating a deal
that
going to be unhappy with and that and
you think of all the things could
potentially go wrong and how you can get
out of it if something goes wrong but
equally important is you know distracted
trying to strike a fair balance with the
people you know go skating win and when
when we're looking internally you
mentioned how your teammates at the
record company thought you were crazy
when you brought up the airline are
there any business ideas that you're
glad your co-workers or team have
prevented you from doing yes I have
books like screw it just do it
and I think be honest if I want to do
something one of one of the advantages
of owning the company is I can normally
ultimately get away with it I mean I'll
try it obviously two-carat carry people
to me but and I'm sure they've been one
or two things which I where I have fully
believe the process true where I regret
it or not regret it I've never regretted
anything but where perhaps I should have
listened more to others which and I
can't think of anything that's you know
where they persuaded me not to do it I
think most likely you know when it comes
to a decision about whether to do
something or not I'm gonna like to think
of myself as a benevolent dictator have
gone into space travel will come to that
I'm sure later on in this talk you know
unless I was to do to do things against
the against the sense for you know what
would you know on paper be sensible
advice that my fellow directors well we
will definitely get the space travel
what I'm curious about because it seems
if I look at many of the businesses that
you've started the positioning is often
against a particular incumbent in the
case of say Airlines for instance that
seems to be a common element in a lot of
the company or product launches and I
want to connect that with just some of
your well-known adventures and you'll
see where this is going in a second I
mean you've driven a tank down Fifth
Avenue across the english channel in an
amphibious car took a four hundred and
seven foot jump
The Palms Casino Resort in Las Vegas
gone from Morocco to Hawaiian hot-air
balloon
you you are very very adept at PR stunts
getting attention for the things that
you do in the companies that you do it
is are there any particular best
practices or a playbook that you have
found to be very or principles for that
matter helpful with the launching of
eight a new company or product Thanks I
mean I'm a great believer in Iying if
your team worked really hard to to
launch a new business with you or for
you at least I think I can do is make a
fool of myself make sure that that new
business ends up on the front page of
the newspapers rather than an anecdote
on the pages of newspapers so if that
means having to use myself to put the
new company on the map I will do so and
I will try to do it in a way that makes
a little smile and that that doesn't
horribly backfire on me especially it
has bad you know and I suppose it's like
being a host to a party I mean if you're
the host of the party if you stand in
the corner of the room and you sip your
sherry and stand around with your fellow
directors all in suits everyone's going
to have a thoroughly dull party and yeah
nobody'll have a good time if you're you
know the host of the party and you're
first in the swing pool and and
everybody else jump in - yeah they may
be a bit cold for the rest the evening
you know they're going to have a great
evening
and I think the same applies when you're
launching a business you know make sure
that you put it on the map and and just
occasionally it will it will backfire
you mentioned space travel which I do
want to use as a touching off point to
ask you roughly 50 years after starting
your first business why why right
finding my virginity what was the the
catalyst for that why do it I actually
think everybody should write a book
about their lives I persuaded a number
of people to write books about their
lives Steve Fossett for instance and a
number of people
but it you know you don't have to let a
very public life I think everyone's led
interesting lives your children and your
grandchildren you know will be
fascinated by the lives the lives you
lead and so I wrote a book on losing my
virginity when I was a young man a
battle all the adventures you know it
became a best-seller and sold millions
of copies but you know I was I was quite
a young man when I wrote it and the last
20 years or so I've have been very full
and very rich and you know extraordinary
so so I thought I would write in a sense
of sequel to losing my opportunity with
you which we call finding my virginity
and and if I live another 20 years a
virginity found I suspect could be my
last we'll see how we go but no but I
think you know I think it's important I
loved reading reading and learning and I
think other others might enjoy hope you
enjoy it and you know when I write books
I tried to I'd try not to make them like
her you know and and then and then we
did this and then we did that just try
to make it a really good gripping read
and and an enjoyable read and and not
try to sort of cram in everything once
done in 20 years but and and hopefully
people can get a few gems from it as
well what is the book or books you've
given most as a gift and why outside
outside of your own book so there any
particular books that you've given or
recommended to others the most well
climate change is something which I've
spent a lot of time on I would highly
recommend a book by Tim Flannery of the
weather makers which was one of the
books that opened my eyes to the
problems that we have in the world I'm
just reading home ideas which which I
find is and I will carry on to reach
sapiens is his first book or one of his
first books and I just love love love
this style of his writing and and you
know I love books where you're learning
you're learning something from them and
rather than about if I want to if I want
fiction I'll get a good film out so if
I'm if I'm reading books I'd like to
read books which have got some substance
I loved in the last let's just call it
five years or so what new belief
behavior or habit has most improved your
life or it what what habit has improved
your life could be any new belief
behavior or habit that has markedly
improved your life I think oh yeah we
gain oh we can go back we can go back as
far as I like absolutely one of the best
things my parents taught me and going
back a long way if I ever said anything
about anybody they would sit me in front
of the mirror and the 10 minutes and in
order to sort of let me know how badly
it reflected on me so you know like to
think I've never gently I generally
never spoken ill about other people and
I think that's been one of the one of
the you know best bits of advice that
I've ever given I'm sorry I've ever
received or and obviously then given
Archbishop Tutu who chaired the elders
which was an organization that we've run
for for 10 years now you know he was the
epitome of forgiveness with the Truth
and Reconciliation Commission in South
Africa when Nelson Mandela you know took
over power and you know I think just you
know people nations you know it should
we should all try to run based on that
philosophy and I think the world would
be a happier place if that if that
happened you you mentioned Nelson
Mandela this is clearly not one of my
stock rabid for our questions but I've
heard you refer to Nelson as a mentor
are there any key lessons or takeaways
or memorable sentences or anything that
come to mind when you think of your
interactions with Nelson Mandela very
well yes even to the extent that on July
the 18th we shared a birthday and and he
would ring me every single birthday to
wish me a happy birthday and you know
remember
yeah the sadness when I didn't get that
call not so many years ago you know he
had an absolute joy for life and you
know he would dance he would smile he
would embrace everybody but he had a
tough sight in as well and I remember
one lunch I had with him early on in our
relationship where you know I'd been
warned that he was always trying to
extract money for good causes so you
know we had the first course then we had
the second course then we had the
pudding and we were on to the coffee and
I thought my god I put away with it and
and then and then he turns to me and
says I Richard last week I had lunch
with Bill Gates and he gave me fifty
million dollars for such and such
recourse and anyway so he did not miss
an opportunity yeah yeah many apart from
maybe Archbishop Tutu I've really never
met and that haven't let anybody as
extraordinary in my lifetime this thing
[Music]
well there you have it folks I hope you
enjoyed this episode of the Tim Ferriss
radio hour focusing on success and more
importantly the prerequisites some of
the ingredients that lead to success and
very often it's by focusing on the
mindsets and the approaches and the
tools that leads you to success as
opposed to chasing the specter that you
might call success these radio our
episodes continue to be an experiment so
I always appreciate your feedback let
you know what you did like let me know
what you didn't like how we can improve
it or other topics or themes that you'd
like me to cover so please let me know
on Twitter at T Ferriss TF PR Riss and
until next time thank you so much
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's four hour work week com
all spelled out and just drop in your
email and you will get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy this
episode is brought to you by 99designs
I've used 99designs for ages since even
before podcasting was the thing and I've
used them for all sorts of graphic
design needs they are fast and they are
convenient whether you need a logo a
website book cover or anything else I've
done competitions for instance for book
covers related to the 4-hour body
99designs
makes great design accessible to
everyone and it makes the process so
much easier and I use them recently for
artwork and illustrations inside of Mike
Tao of Seneca set of books so this is a
collection of stoic writing and modern
interviews and so on so for the Tao of
Seneca I decided to use their one-to-one
project surface in this case you invite
a specific designer to your project
agree on a price and then work together
until you're satisfied and the artwork
just blew my mind
you have to check it out I kid you not
so you can check out some of the artwork
from Toph Seneca as well as some artwork
and logos and so on that your fellow
listeners have had made at 99 designs
calm forward-slash Tim that's 99designs
calm forward-slash Tim I really suggest
you check it out
and right now you guys can receive a
free $99 upgrade on your first project
this gets you I think a hundred and
thirty percent more submissions so
people who want to work with you and
give you first drafts of what you're
looking for
to access your free design please visit
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim and
click the link on the landing page
that's 99designs dot-com forward slash
Tim
you